Dave pallone was a baseball umpire from
1979 through 1988 and kind enough to
join us now Dave thanks for joining us
that's the reason why we're having you
on your thoughts of the automated strike
zone well then how would you ever get an
umpire to throw out a guy twice that's
all that's the same bat I mean if we
have electronic umpire can't happen you
know that just happened last night never
happened to microwave or the guy out
twice at the same play but that's beside
the point
I think balls and strikes are part of
have been part of the game naturally
forever and if you take away the human
element of it I just think it ruins the
game baseball you know I was all in
favor of the instant replay for fair and
foul fan interference but this you know
sakes and outs and all that other stuff
that goes along was instant replay I
just think it takes away the human
element of the game I explained this to
me though why was there a strike zone
for the American League and one for the
National League well it started way back
when if you remember the American League
umpires used that balloon protector yep
and it made them and they made them sit
up higher and so it gave them the higher
strike zone because they really couldn't
see the knees and where the National
League umpires you know we had the you
know they started off where the
protective and went to the chest and so
they could get further down lower down
and they could see the knee but they
really couldn't see the higher strike
zone so that's where when I was up
hiring the strike zone kind of maybe
just a little bit above the waistline
and that's the bottom of the knee and
we're and the American League when they
used the balloon it was chest high and
maybe maybe at the belt but never down
by the knee
what did you I was the difference what's
your biggest problem our concern about
the strike zone now balls and strikes
well my two things are number one I you
know it's easy for me to say this
because I'm retired but you know I do
not like the inconsistency you know one
thing is easy for me to say your typical
Navy that I'm saying this but I think I
was consistent people knew that I was
going to call a lot of strikes maybe an
institution Institute off home off home
plate from a right-handed batter and a
left-handed batter fastball two inches
off the plate you know you're standing
there looking at it you can't see that I
can but the batter can't why not call
that a strike let the game go faster
that's why we have three four hour games
is because you know but the games are
not call the way the umpires wants to
call them I'm old-school I know that but
having a having a fastball come in about
a half an inch an inch off home plate
you know that it's not that big and I
don't see how a player can actually see
that they said that Ted Williams just to
see it maybe I don't know but don't know
how you do it do you think we're headed
towards the automatic you know automated
strike zone from what I've been reading
yes but I would hate to see it you know
the case when I watch baseball now on TV
I hate the K zone I mean it's just so
horrible I just hate it because the
umpires can't really control the game
the way they should control the game you
know I go back to cut it I mean think of
it this way
it's eight to nothing top of the ninth
the two else pitch comes in and the K
zone it's a ball because it's one inch
off the place I mean if it was if I was
on fire
I'd be calling it a strike because why
are you not swinging when it's a can up
in any losing you know why are you not I
don't get the game goes too long that
it's going to be even longer with
whether or not it made a strike sauce
you were pointing out fires yeah go
ahead Larry well I mean the umpires are
integral part of this game and I mean
they have been since double date
naturally and I think taking them away
from the game it's going to ruin the
game
I mean I mean you know fans love to see
a good argument and you won't have any
arguments and balls two strikes but the
umpires done you also I think are quoted
as saying you weren't afraid to be hated
explain what that means being an umpire
well and be able to control the game
and just as I said you know calling the
strike off the play two inches off the
plate that means that maybe the guys
going to give you a hard time and you
know you cannot be afraid to take a hard
time if you're gonna make a hard
decision you know I used to make hard
decisions easy again egotistical as it
sounds I used to make hard decisions but
I think they would go against players
they didn't they didn't children
understand why I would call this because
some players wouldn't call the players I
called and I had I think I had enough
guts to call and that's why you have to
be okay to be hated because you are
going to be hated gonna be hated by the
home home fans you're gonna be hated by
visiting ballplayers home but ball
players you are going to be quote
unquote hated but you have to be okay to
be hated in order to be good at what you
do we staple own former baseball umpire
joining us Dan Patrick show explain this
to me the logic of if Greg Maddux throws
a pitch off the plate he'll get that
pitch or Tom Glavine where is the the
pedestrian pitcher won't get that or if
Wade Boggs Tony Gwynn take a pitch
therefore it's probably a ball why do
the best players get the calls or more
calls or at least the appearance than
the regular guys say that you answered
your own question but you know the best
you know the players that you name or
the best of what they do because they
were always consistent you know you take
for instance though they call a Nolan
Ryan for instance you know his 100 mana
or fastball 90% 95% was always around
the plate always right there you know
remember think about Johnny Bench when
he caught there was a rule that we we
followed with Johnny Bench if he moved
his glove a little bit to the left a
little bit to the right up or down it
was gonna be a strike because that's how
he caught he made it always look good
and a picture with great control like a
Steve Carlton a Nolan Ryan
Glavine Maddox great control you don't
have to worry about it you can call that
pitch a strike even though it might be a
little bit off the plate or a little bit
below the knees because he's always
going to be there but you get a guy that
throws the 10 feet above the guy
Ted all the time and you know two feet
outside all the time and all of a sudden
he throws the pitch that's two inches
off the plate why should you call that a
strike but if it's something that's
always consistent why not give it it
makes the game go quicker that is the
big key that's why we're losing a lot of
fans and they Major League Baseball
today because the games are so long they
can't stand being there I for the first
time as since I've been going to
baseball games after I've retired I went
to a Rockies game Dodger game the game
lasted two hours and 40 minutes and it's
the first time that I can remember that
I stayed the entire nine is because the
game was a good game and it was a fast
game and two hours and 40 minutes when I
was on prime was the longest what's the
moment that sticks out now I know you
had your moment with Pete Rose but is
there a moment during your umpiring
career that stands out good or bad one
yes I think it was the 87 Playoffs
between the Giants and the Cardinals
going back to being hated
there was a call where it involved
Coleman from the Cardinals Vince Coleman
he ran out of the base yep he ran out of
the base line the ball was thrown over
his head the first baseman couldn't
catch it went down the line I call time
I put the runner back the first called
him out so forth and so on
it's a gutsy call that's a call that a
lot of umpires don't make but you have
to make that call because that's what
that box is there for it for you to run
inside that box two feet have to be in
that box so one foot has to be on the
white line and the other would have to
be in the box he didn't do that
that's an 87 playoff game and Ozzie
Smith I'll never I'll never forget how
he cannot meet the Dave you always make
these calls against us why and I'll and
my response was because it's a rule and
you gotta follow the rules pretty simple
explain the Pete Rose moment that you
had you know that's 30 years ago yes
this year not 30 years I can't believe
it I know 30 years you know I was just
asked this question the other day did I
hit up I never touched Pete Rose it's
easy for me to say that easy for me to
say that I
like that but I never touched Pete you
know the play was one of those where s
ASCII was off the bag but he but Mookie
Wilson hadn't reached the bag yet he
hadn't and sassy was off the bed but he
still had time to get on to the bag and
I had to delay the call until something
happened and what happened was monkey
Wilkins finally got to the bag ended up
being safe and you think it was the
first game of the world series but it
was only April 30th you know it was only
like the fifth game of the year but it's
pretty much said that Pete had a bet on
the game so that's why he went berserk
now he he said you bumped him first
right but he he forced you right right I
never I never touched him I mean I never
bumped him you can watch the replay many
times it's on my youtube channel you can
watch it he's saying that I scratched
his face well he has also said that he
took a fingernail clipper after the game
and scratched his face with the script
with the fingernail clipper so that it
would look like I poked him in the eye
or poked him on the face rather and
scratched him on the face but that never
happened I mean you could slow it down
and slow it down the best you can mother
the old-time technology and see that my
finger never touched him and I know I
didn't it's easy for me to say that I
know but I know I never custom but he
certainly pushed me into Kentucky but he
pushed me do you think that he had a bet
on the game oh there's no question I
didn't know it then I did not know it
then that's way but there's no question
after did you did you have any
suspicions that people's betting on
games back then I knew that it was a
heavy gambler you know I knew that he
was heavy gambler you know it's easy for
me to say that I had an inkling the
gutter belt was that he was but I
personally never knew it to say that he
absolutely was I knew other things about
baseball players during my career but
nothing about Pete as far as betting on
the game itself what did you know about
players
well there were players that I was
living in New York and you know and
that's a young guy single guy going out
and going out city of New York and you'd
run into players certain players would
come up to me Here I am amazingly
baseball umpire trying to mind my own
business end up in the same bar and
nightclub as some of the players and
have them come up to me and said you
know anybody can get me cooked and I
would say no and I would walk away so
they're coming up to a current umpire
asking if you can score some coke no not
on fire please oh yeah no you were an
umpire yeah correct yes correct and
players would come up to me and ask me
if I knew anyone that could get some
coke I mean that's the kind of things
that you know you don't talk about very
often but it happened happens all the
time I don't know what happens today
naturally but it happened back in the
you know eighties when I was there we
don't see Zika me to say that I know but
that's just the way it is what else did
you know I knew it I did know well you
remember the story about the Pittsburgh
parrot I mean I knew about that him
selling coke to players I know about
that
I knew about umpires doing you know
leather Ibiza the gambling that the
umpires had whether it be you know
whether it be extramarital affairs
whatever it might be is not it's not my
business to say and I certainly would
never mention names and again easy for
me to say that I I know who they are but
I'm certainly not going to out them
because I don't believe in that but
anything I say now at my age I would
assume that it's the truth if it is did
you say that umpires were gambling yeah
a real question we'll explain that now
I'm not saying okay I'm not saying that
they were gambling on the games
themselves you know the baseball games
I'm not saying that so don't miss
misconstrue okay I'm saying
but but not about baseball games no no
absolutely not
oh so it could have been football or
horse-racing or select everything that
they weren't supposed to be doing
right right correct what's good to catch
up with you Dave
hope retirements treating you well and
we appreciate you joining us thank you
so much they greatly appreciate it and I
enjoy your show always have and haven't
seen Joe since the all-star game at the
courts field way back when as a long
time ago oh yeah I think I took my son
to that game yeah a long time ago but
that's the last time you and I had seen
each other but we've spoken since then
well it's good to catch up with you
again Dave we appreciate your time thank
you all right thank you come on that's a
day plone former baseball umpire for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]